simonet bonjour et merci d'être en
direct avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
info vous faites partie des élus qui se
sont rendus devant l'un des
commissariats de paris où étaient
retenus certains manifestants qu
avez-vous observé écoutez moi j'étais
devant le commissariat du xxème
arrondissement où il y avait plusieurs
personnes qui étaient en garde à vue et
notamment une jeune fille de 17 ans qui
est la fille d'une colle d'une camarade
et collègue conseiller régional ile de
france bénédicte manville est ce qu'il
faut bien comprendre c'est que cette
jeune mineur qui a été arrêté pendant la
manifestation de samedi n'avait rien
fait de particulier à part qu'elles
manifestaient et qu'elle filmait la
police
et donc elle a été arrêtée mise en garde
à vue et enfin c'est totalement
insupportable intolérable parce qu'on a
le sentiment et et les témoignages
d'eric coquerel députées françaises
soumises qui a pu aller dans différents
commissariats et rencontrer un certain
nombre de personnes qui étaient en garde
à vue a pu constater que beaucoup de
personnes ont fait l'objet
d'arrestations abusives et que la
stratégie de monsieur darmanin et de
monsieur lallement préfet de police de
paris
visiblement de dissuader de manifester
et c'est totalement intolérables cette
dérive autoritaire qui vise à remettre
en cause le droit de manifester parce
qu'on a vraiment pas mal de personnes
qui ont fait l'objet d'un mandat
d'arrestation sans qu'il y ait de raison
réelle tous à la fois pour dissuader et
puis aussi pour faire toute une campagne
de communication comme quoi le
gouvernement est bien aurait arrêté ce
qui était violent ce qu'ils cassaient or
il n'en est rien et c'est totalement
insupportable justement c'est à cause
des casseurs que le gouvernement a pris
a mis en place cette nouvelle stratégie
on va dire du maintien
de l'ordre une stratégie gagnante selon
la préfecture de police de paris qui
s'est félicité de la bonne tenue de la
manifestation
comment vous réagissez à cette
déclaration
non c'est une stratégie pertes c'est une
stratégie perdante parce que vous avez
vous avez eu des interventions
policières un moment donné qui qui
coupait les les cortèges qui arrêtaient
de manière arbitraire des personnes qui
n'avaient rien fait de mal et qui se
sont vus donc empêcher de manifester qui
se sont retrouvés donc en situation
gardes à vue abusives
c'est comment est ce qu'on peut se
satisfaire d'une dérive autoritaire qui
remet ainsi en cause le droit de
manifester enfin c'est totalement
scandaleux donc je le redis encore un
des arrestations abusives de en fait on
a l'impression d'une opération de
manipulation qui fait croire et bien que
les policiers ont arrêté ceux qui
avaient commis des actes de violence
alors qu'ils ont arrêtés bien souvent
des manifestants au hasard ça ça peut
pas être tolérable
donc on voit bien que la revendication
du retrait total de la loi sécurité
globale est toujours nécessaire légitime
et qu'il doit rester légitime de
manifester dans paris pour demander ce
retrait la qui plus est après et bien
les trois décrets qui ont été paru qui
sont parus le 2 décembre et qui en plus
franchisse un cap à travers le
renforcement des droits de fichage
politique
donc on voit bien que le gouvernement
macro et là dans une dérive autoritaire
totalement inacceptables pour la
préservation de nos libertés
fondamentales alors l'agenda social
risque d'être chargé en 2021 peut
s'attendre à de nouvelles manifestations
bien évidemment est ce que vous craignez
justement d'autres arrestations
arbitraires d'autres dérives lors de
futurs rassemblements bien sûr agir
c'est quand même dingue c'est que la
tâche du préfet l'allemand la tâche du
ministre de l'intérieur
ça doit notamment être de garantir le
droit de manifester or là ils sont en
train de remettre en cause ce droit là
et ils poursuivent toujours le même
agenda de casse sociale 1
ils n'ont pas abandonné la volonté de
casser notre système de retraite ils
sont en train d'essayer de casser
démanteler edf ya il ya tout terrain un
agenda de politique ultralibérale anti
sociale alors que la pauvreté est en
train d'exploser dans ce pays qu'il ya
énormément de licenciement que la
culture est très durement attaqué et on
voit bien qu'à travers cet agenda très
libéral eh bien il ya aussi un agenda
d'une dérive autoritaire inacceptable la
loi sécurité globale aussi la loi
séparatistes et aussi ces décrets et je
dis attention nous sommes regardés par
le monde entier la france est en train
de basculer dans un autre régime
un régime autoritaire il y a de quoi
être très inquiet il faut au contraire
se mobiliser pour défendre nos libertés
et pour défendre que l'urgence ce serait
une toute autre politique qui réponde
aux besoins sociaux il ya l'urgence
écologique
merci beaucoup danielle simonnet d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes conseillère de paris à la
france insoumise